OK, welcome, everyone.
My name is Stephen Naron and I'm the
director of the Fortunoff Video
Archive for Holocaust Testimonies.
And it really is an honor for the
archive to be hosting this event
this morning to celebrate the
enormous scholarly contributions
of Professor Lawrence Langer and
welcome the publication of a series
of articles in his honor,
in the honor of his storied career
and influence, entitled
"Interrogating Evil: A special
issue of the Journal of Holocaust
research for Lawrence Langer on his
90th birthday."
Larry is not only the most important
living thinker and writer on the
topic of Holocaust testimonies
from the Fortunoff Video Archives,
but he's also helped to build the
archive, having served as an
interviewer on over 80 testimonies
recorded by the archive since the
late 1980s. It's impossible
for me to overstate the
enormous influence Larry has had
on the shape of this archive and its
reception in the scholarly
community.
But I suspect other speakers today
will address that much better than I
can.
I would like to make one tiny
announcement that I think is
relevant and I hope Larry will
appreciate.
And that is, uh, I met recently with
representatives of Yale University
Press, and together
we are discussing the
creation of a multimedia version
of Larry's book, Holocaust
Testimonies: Ruins of Memory,
which would combine the text of his
groundbreaking work with the
original excerpts from the
testimonies upon which Larry based
his research.
In doing so, Ruins of Memory will
not only continue to tell us
about its own important insights
that can be drawn from testimony,
but it will show us those important
insights.
Larry, I hope to have it ready for
you before your 92nd
birthday, bis 120. So
now I'd like to hand things
over to Michal Aharony.
Michal is the editor of the Journal
of Holocaust Research and
is a teaching fellow at Ben-Gurion
University.
She received her Ph.D.
in Political Science from the New
School for Social, Social Research
in 2010.
Her research and teaching interests
include history of political ideas
in modern political thought and
Holocaust studies.
She's the author of Hannah Arendt
and the Limits of Total Domination,
The Holocaust Plurality
and Resistance from Routledge, 2015,
and numerous articles
and chapters.
Michal, you have the floor.
Don't forget to unmute, Michal.
Hi, can you hear me now?
Hi, so hello, everyone.
Good morning. Here in Israel, it's
already 5:00 in the afternoon.
I'm very happy to be here in this
special event to honor
Professor
Langer's 90th birthday and his
great contribution to Holocaust
studies.
I want to say just
briefly a few words about
the journal for the sake of
people who don't know the
journal.
So the Journal of Holocaust
Research, formerly known as Dapim,
is the Academic Journal of the
Weiss-Livnat International
Center for Holocaust Research
and Education at
the University of Haifa.
It is published in, with
coorporation
with Taylor and Francis
publications.
And we publish
each year four volumes
in English and also
once a year a volume,
a bigger volume in Hebrew.
So it's bilingual.
And on behalf of the journal,
I would like to take this
opportunity to thank,
first of all, Larry,
for giving us
the opportunity
to publish this special
volume in his honor
and also for his beautiful
article that he contributed
for this volume.
Second,
I would like to thank the three
guest editors, Dawn Skorczewski, Dan
Stone, and Gabriel Finder.
Thank you for your wonderful
cooperation and for all
the effort and hard work
that
made this special
volume possible.
For me personally, it was a
great privilege to work
with all of you.
And of course, and
to read Larry's
piece and to work carefully on all
this...all the very
interesting and great
articles that all of you
contributed.
And,
we worked hard for over,
I think, one year
and a half. And I'm very happy to
be here tonight.
And finally, I want to thank
the Fortunoff Video Archive
at Yale University for
organizing this special
event. So thank you, everyone,
and I hope everyone will enjoy this
webinar.
Thank you, Michal and thank you,
Stephen. I'd just like to say
a few words on behalf of the
editors. That's
Dawn and Gabi and myself.
First of all, we'd like to
say thank you to the Fortunoff
Archive for hosting this event,
which, of course, would be nicer in
person. But
such,
such is life.
We have to put up with, with this
instead.
But maybe at some point we'll be
able to do something in, in
person. That's wonderful, Stephen,
to hear of the plans for, for
Larry's book. That's really, that's
really exciting.
And secondly, to thank
Michal because what she said is, is
true. A lot, a lot of work has gone
into this journal.
And we as editors,
I think, are extremely pleased with
the results. In the end, we've
got a great range of
articles, very different sorts
of contributions, but all of them
reflecting on
and celebrating Larry's
work. And that's the points
we're really happy
to be able to present this
collection to, Larry, slightly
late for
his 90th birthday, only a year late,
but you know, never mind what's a
year? So
congratulations to Larry.
And I'm now going to invite
each of the contributors to speak
very briefly for three or four
minutes each in
the order that they appear in
the journal.
And then I'll invite Larry to
respond.
And then if there are any questions
in the chat or in the Q&A, then
I will read
out as many as we can in the time
that we have available to us.
So I'd like first to ask
Joanne Rudof to speak.
Joanne is the Laurel Fox
Vlock fellow at the Fortunoff
Archive at Yale. Joanne.
Oops, unmute
Joanne. There we go.
Thank you Dan.
Thank you Michal.
And thank you, Stephen.
Hello to the authors, most of whom I
know. And a special, special
hello to Larry.
Hello also to everyone else who has
taken the time to be with us for
this wonderful occasion.
Even if only virtually.
And thank you to the Fortunoff Video
Archive for initiating and
hosting this event.
When I was approached on April 5th,
2019, to write this piece
for the Journal, I was first
delighted to hear that my good
friend and mentor extraordinaire,
Larry Langer, was to be honored on
the occasion of his 90th birthday
with a special issue of the journal.
Second, I was very pleased to
be part of this effort.
My journal article has a research
focus documenting Larry's career,
the history of the Fortunoff Video
Archive for Holocaust Testimonies,
the connections
between Larry and Fortunoff since
1984, and the symbiosis
resulting in extraordinary
intellectual and research
impact since its
beginning and continuing to
the present and into the future.
In contrast to the research focus
of the article, today I
will focus on the personal.
Larry is extraordinarily
generous in sharing his
experience and his expertise.
He is always willing to share his
phone number with anyone interested
in discussing his work,
particularly with young scholars.
He invites them to his home.
He recommends to them what they
should be reading and viewing.
And even more important, he listens
to their ideas and learns
from them.
I have always considered myself
among one of the luckiest of those
working in our field
because of my mentors, my
extraordinary mentors.
Geoffrey
Hartman, Sam Kassow, Dana Kline,
Sandra Rosenstock, and Larry Langer.
No course, no degree
program, no seminar
could begin to cover what I have
learned from all of them.
In particular, Larry taught
me how to view video testimonies.
When I began this work, although
each testimony had a huge impact
on me, I was really at
a loss in terms of seeing
patterns and critical
analysis.
Larry's generosity in sharing
his ideas contributed greatly
to my own development as a scholar,
as an archivist, as a documentarian
and as a writer.
I dare say there are countless
others who would say the very
same thing.
Larry's sense of humor,
his optimism, his
respect for others and his
ethics in terms of Holocaust
survivors and testimonies...but
equally important, his life,
combined with his tremendous
intellect, his insatiable
curiosity and impulse
to continually add to his knowledge,
his wit, his incomparable
writing,
all combined to make him truly
a giant in our field,
not only in the academy, but
in the world at large.
His loving and close family are
the focus of his life.
My Zaide, my grandpa, would
call him a Mensch,
a Talmid Chocham, and perhaps even
an lamed vavnik. My Zaide, would
also have me say to Larry today,
gey gezunterheyt biz 120. Larry, I
wish
you many more Simhats and many
more great grandchildren,
particularly seeing the immense joy
that the babies Dana and Maya
have brought to you. Larry, L'chaim.
Thank you so much,
Joanne. That's really a lovely way
to begin.
Can I next ask
Jennifer, Jennifer
Geddes to speak.
Jennifer is a professor
in the Department of Religious
Studies at the University of
Virginia.
Thank you. I am delighted to be here
today and really honored
to have been asked to contribute an
essay to this special issue
of the Journal of Holocaust
Research. So many thanks to the
editors, Dawn, Dan and Gabi for all
your work in bringing the issue into
being.
And thanks to the Fortunoff Archive
for organizing this event today.
Like all of us
here, I have learned so much from
reading Larry Langer's work,
a learning that has influenced
my writing and my teaching.
I have seen the light of realization
on my students' faces as
they encountered his concept of
choiceless choice and its
implications for thinking about the
Holocaust.
I have seen them begin to understand
their own temptations to domesticate
the Holocaust, after reading
his descriptions of the ways we try
to preempt, use, and abuse
the Holocaust. And they
have come to see the inadequacy of
language in grappling with the
Holocaust through his work.
As Larry tells
us, quote, "the ghastly details
of the Holocaust are a constant
reminder of the abyss separating
the lived experience of those who
endured it from the language
that seeks to describe it," end
quote.
In my essay, " Consider If: Levi,
Langer, Agamben, and the
Unthinkable,"
I bring some of these things I have
learned from Langer's work into
conversation with Primo Levi's "If
this is a Man" and Giorgio Agamben's
"Remnants of Auschwitz." Beginning
with Charlotte Delbo's distinction
between the worst and the
unthinkable, I try
to explore the unthinkable as
marking not the impossibility of
thought, but rather a space
that requires us to engage
in sustained reflection
that refuses clear judgments or
conclusions.
I suggest that Levi's use of the
hypothetical, of "if" clauses,
create such a space and commands
us to engage in this kind of
reflection.
Specifically, I explore Levi's
command that we consider if the men
and women on the brink of exhaustion
and death in the concentration
camps, those who have been called
the Muselmänner, are human.
I suggest that this activity of
"considering if" is one
that must not come to a conclusion
that is characterized by hesitation,
that requires a bracketing of
conclusion.
I then connect this mode of ongoing
reflection in which judgment is
bracketed to Langer's
idea of choiceless choice,
suggesting that it, too, calls
for an ongoing attention and
engagement with the testimonies of
survivors, along with a bracketing
of moral judgment.
And finally, I turn to Agamben's
meditation on the Muselmann
in "Remnants of Auschwitz," arguing
that while the book seems to be
precisely this kind of reflection
without judgment or resolution,
Agamben actually fails to keep open
the space of reflection, conflating
victim and perpetrator in the
process. Where Levi
hesitates and Langer advises
caution, Agamben
advances conclusions.
In the end, I suggest that the
unthinkable, while sometimes
functioning as a cliche,
can also mark a space in
which we are called to dwell,
listen and "consider if,"
a reflection that cannot conclude
or assert confident conclusions.
I think this caution, this
willingness to continue to engage
the ghastly details that cannot
be fully understood is
something that Langer's work has
again and again taught me.
And I am very grateful and
Happy Birthday.
Thank you, Jennifer.
That's really wonderful and also
lovely comments to hear.
So our next speaker is
Sara Horowitz who is a professor
at the Koschitzky Center for Jewish
Studies at York University.
So, Sara.
Thank you. I'm going to echo
my colleagues in thanking the
editors of this volume
and of the journal itself for
bringing this into fruition.
I know it's always difficult
to wrangle essays
into a cohesive volume as
they have done.
But I do want to suggest that their
task was made a little bit lighter
by the inspiration that the honoree
has for all of
us contributors.
And I want to begin by briefly
saying that in a field that's
been dominated, and perhaps rightly
so, by historians that
study the Holocaust, Larry Langer
is a luminary.
He brought the tools and
methodologies of literary
scholarship to deepen
and enrich thinking about the
Holocaust. He's influenced people
in a range of discipline with
his rigorous, insightful,
and powerful voice.
He has not only teased
out the subtleties and
nuances of writing
and testimonies about the Holocaust,
but he's also been a steady
critic of cultural misappropriations
of the Holocaust and
calling out as a kind of bad
faith the tendencies to
view the Shoah through
a redemptive lens.
His work has always been
characterized by clear thinking
and writing, by passion
and by a steady moral compass.
I met Larry as a graduate student
in the late 80s when I asked him
on our first meeting whether
everything had already been said
about Holocaust literature.
And I think Larry's own work
since the late 70s
is certainly evidence that it had
not yet been already
said.
As I said, Larry has been a luminary
in the field for me.
His, he's been more.
He's been a generous mentor
and truly a lifelong
inspiration.
And so happy
birthday. And as we say in Yiddish,
tsu lange yor, a very long
life.
I'm going to briefly summarize my
contribution to the volume,
which very much bears
the imprint of Larry's
insistence that we
not look for redemptive narratives
about the Holocaust.
I...my article is a reading of
the belated memoir
of the now "Rue Ordener, Rue Labat"
by the French philosopher Sarah
Kofman, placed in the context
of fictional and nonfictional
accounts by writers who like
Kaufman, survived the Shoah
as children.
Kofman was a child in Paris,
born to immigrant parents from
Poland, who Orthodox Jews.
Her father was the rabbi of
a Paris synagogue.
He was tipped off in advance about
what came to be called the
Vel' d'Hiv rafle.
And after warning his congregants,
he returned home to his own
apartment and waited to be arrested,
hoping that in so doing he would buy
time for his wife and six
children.
And indeed he did.
He was murdered in Auschwitz but the
rest of his family survived.
The memoir centers on a period of
time when Sarah, as a child,
and her mother lived out the war
sheltered by a French Catholic
neighbor who took them into her
apartment. More than 30 years
after the liberation of Paris,
Kofman initiated
the process to have her rescuer
designated by Yad Vashem as one
of the righteous among the nations.
But her memoir focuses
on what you
might call the dark side of being
hidden child.
It would appear that Sarah is
very lucky. She never was separated
from her mother, and she lived out
the war, as did all of her siblings.
But the memoir focuses
on the way
her relationship with this woman
and the increasing powerlessness
of her own mother caused
a stress, a
break in the relationship of her
mother and a
kind of attenuation of her
relationship to Judaism as well.
I put this in the context of
writers like Appelfeld and
Louis Begley, where we can see
in the account of children during
the Holocaust a kind
of...anti-Bildungsroman.
In other words, a kind of
undoing of the self, undoing
of the foundations of the self
so that who they become later
is severely marked
by what they went through.
The memo was written in Sarah
Kofman's 60th year and shortly
before her suicide by
gas. And it functions, in a sense,
as a coda to her more abstract
and intellectual work published
several years earlier called
"Paroles suffoquées",
or Smothered Words.
There she asks, how can
it be said and how can it not
be said? In her, in
her work, I very much...I'm
indebted to Larry's insistence
that we see not only what
it is that people say in
the writing, but also the things
that they cannot say.
And often that they cannot bear to
think. So thank you, Larry,
for being my moral
compass.
Thank you, Sara.
More lovely comments.
I see some common threads developing
here, which I'll
comment on a little later.
Our next speaker then is
Noah Shenker.
Noah is based at the Australian
Center for Jewish Civilization at
Monash University in Australia.
And we're particularly grateful to
him for being here since it's about
two o'clock in the morning
where he is.
So Noah, if you're still awake, then
we'd love to hear from you.
Though
I write about artificial
intelligence, I am currently
sentient.
I just want to start by saying
that though I've only
known Larry
for the last six or seven
years, I remember him first
meeting him at
AJS, the Association for Jewish
Studies, I believe it was in
Baltimore. And
I was just greatly
intimidated by the prospect of
meeting someone who had loomed so
large for me and I just recall
the warmth and his
generosity and
his, his frank
and, and, and
honest views
on everything, including my own
work, which were just incredibly
foundational
to helping me
pursue the path that I've been on.
Though I first encountered Larry's
work and I remember exactly when
it was...I had just
decided upon a
topic for my dissertation
on the mediation of Holocaust's
testimony. And as a film and media
scholar, I
felt in over my head.
I had read a great
deal about the Holocaust.
I had
done work
going back to my undergraduate
career, looking at representations
of the Holocaust.
But I just didn't have a sense
of how to enter into this discourse.
I needed a guide and that
guide ended up being
Larry. To, to read,
to read his work was to open
up just
a whole world of possibilities for
how it was to understand
testimonies.
I had a sense
in terms of being a Film and media
scholar about how the space of the
screen and the sound of the voice
and the ways in which people
perform and, and
articulate.
But I had no sense of
the kinds of conventions
and the narrative and, and
rapport and all the, the
aspects that went into the process.
And when reading Larry's
formative work, it
opened up for
me what ended up being
the passion that drives my,
my, my career.
And I'm just forever indebted
to Larry for that.
And I'm indebted to the
editors for inviting me, for
giving me this ability,
to feel honored, to be able to
contribute to this volume.
I'm a little emotional just because
it takes me back to first
encountering Larry's work and onto
his, ongoing genorosity and warmth
that he's... an honest,
I can, I cannot stress honesty and
frankness when he has talked
and we've talked about our ideas.
My work for this volume disrupted
narratives. Lawrence Langer's
explorations
of deep memory and Holocaust
testimonies is
a way of trying to trace Larry's
influence, the ways
in which he's been so foundational
and foregrounding the importance
of examining Holocaust testimonies,
giving us the language,
giving us
the sense of the conventions,
which is probably not the best term,
but at least a sense
of the textures
and
the contours of testimonies.
And also
really allowing
historians and other scholars of the
Holocaust to look at testimonies,
not just simply as primary
documents, as primary sources, but
as...of the
representations about their
experiences, but as other sources in
and of themselves. In
short, I think, Larry, more than any
other scholar, has demonstrated
the interwoven nature of history
and of memory as it
makes its way in video testimonies,
whether it's...and I've continued
to...whether it's the students that
I supervise and constantly
return in the classes that I teach
to, to Larry's conceptualization
of the choiceless choice.
And what my work focuses in
on is particularly his
engagement with Charlotte Delbo's
notions of deep and common
memory, and the ways
in which
survivors express common
memory, often in a chronological
or coherent structure,
recalling in the present moment how
events unfolded in a
compartmentalized past and in,
in contrast, notions
of deep memory, taking witnesses
back to the events, reintroducing
them to the range of senses
experienced at the time and
complicating. And this is so, so
foundational, complicating any
efforts to keep that past
at bay.
And that, Larry, more
than any other scholar that I know,
faced...compelling
us to, to engage the paradox
that it is impossible to fully
understand a witness,
but that we must always try to
understand a witness.
That the impossibility
and the obligation that must coexist
in this endeavor has
forever shaped our understanding
of Holocaust testimony.
And I think also of, of, of, of
trauma
more broadly. And I think
of genocides beyond the Holocaust
by way of conclusion.
And as I'm speaking
from Australia and starting to
do work on the Stolen Generations of
Australia and as I've done work
on Cambodia and teach on Rwanda
and other genocides, to see
Larry's conceptualizations
and also his critiques of
other ways of conducting
testimonies that have been done by
various archives across the world,
to see how the debates
that Larry
had mentioned in regards to the
Holocaust continue to inform
in critical ways how
we understand genocide
and testimony, well beyond the
Holocaust.
So, Larry, thank you again
for informing all of this work,
for steering all of this work and
again to the editors for bringing
his work in front
and center where it belongs and as
it always has been.
Thank you Noah. Thank you for your
powerful comments.
Our next speaker is
Dawn Skorczewski.
Dawn is Professor
of Literature at Brandeis University
and she's going to talk
about the article, which
she and I have co-written for this
special issue, which is on
Jan Karski's testimonies.
Dawn, go on.
I'll talk a little bit about the
article. But first, I just want to
say a round of thank yous.
W.S. Merwin's poem "Thank
you" comes to mind.
I don't know if you know it, but
it's just thank you, thank you,
thank you, thank you.
The first thank you has to go to
Lawrence Langer. Larry, I
am filled with emotion as I think
about the many years now.
I mean, almost a decade.
But for me it seems like a very long
time that I've been working with you
and talking to you about Holocaust
testimony, testimonies.
A couple of years ago when you were
about to turn 90, I remember talking
with Dan and thinking...how could,
how could we, how could I ever
repay you for all
that I've learned from you and for
all you've given to the field?
And this volume, which I've so
enjoyed working on with Dan and Gabi
has been a labor
of love, as well as an intellectual,
a very gratifying intellectual
experience.
I first met Larry when I was giving
a talk about Anne
Frank and Etty
Hillesum at the Newton Public Library
in Newton, Massachusetts.
And, and he was in the audience
raising his hand every so often,
correcting the speakers about
some errors in, in their
delivery, things that they were
saying. I was one of those speakers
and I was the one who was getting
the most corrections, I think.
And at the end of the talk, Larry
came to the front of the room and
he said to me, you know, there are a
few things I didn't get to say that
you missed in your talk, that you're
just, you're just wrong about.
And I was thinking, oh my goodness.
I was so taken aback.
And I knew there were probably a lot
of things, but I didn't know who
this person was and I didn't know
what I was going to...how I was
going to respond because the talk
was over.
And I said, well you must know a lot
about this.
And he said, well, you know, I've
written 11 books on the subject.
And I said, oh, maybe I should know
your name. He said, I'm Lawrence
Langer. And I almost fainted.
And I was standing in front of
Lawrence Langer. And then, almost
the next thing that happened was he
graciously invited me to come to his
house and talk more about Holocaust
testimonies.
And we started watching Holocaust
testimonies in his living
room, pretty much once a week.
So I've spent, I don't know, 100,
over 100 hours watching testimonies
with Larry and talking about
so many different aspects of them.
And so you can imagine just from
those words how much...what that
experience could be like.
And then to have the opportunity now
to work on this volume in his
honor and to read the beautiful
essays that you've all written and
to see Larry's face as he listens to
you. It's just such a pleasure.
I'm not going to talk a lot about
the article that Dan and I wrote,
except to say that Dan and I met
a few years ago. And one of our
first conversations was about Larry
Langer, about his work and
also about his interview with
Jan Karski.
I'm just going to show you a picture
that appears in our article, and
I'm sharing my screen here.
It's a picture of Karski and
he's imitating FDR.
And you'll see him right here.
And Dan and I were talking
about this. And I remember Larry
telling me about this, this,
this happening in the interview.
And he said, you have to see this,
this is his Shoah foundation
interview. And then Dan
and I started comparing the Shoah
foundation interview with Larry's
Fortunoff interview with Karski and
then with Claude Lanzmann's Shoah.
And it was such a rich conversation.
And the result of which is in this
article. We conclude the article
with this comment, which
I think is so...it attempts
to capture what Larry
is about as a thinker and scholar.
Thirty years later, Langer's work
helps us to correct a tendency
to focus exclusively
on the traumatic, the historical,
or the performative dimensions
of our recorded testimony.
Instead, we must keep all these
theories handy and at bay as we
listen from moment to moment across
the archives to the individual human
being who endured great suffering
and acted heroically and
in Lanzmann's, and in Karski's case,
who
insisted I can't go back in his
interview with Lanzmann, only to do
so again and again for these
important archives.
It was such a pleasure to work on
this article with Dan.
It went through a few iterations and
one of the most important parts of
that was talking to Larry about the
article.
There's so much more I'd like to say
as far as what a pleasure it's been
to work on this volume and to work
with Larry. But I'm not going to
take up all of our time.
And I want to thank you all for
being here. And thank you, Stephen,
for hosting.
And thank you to the Journal.
And again, thanks to all the
contributors. And finally, thanks
again to Larry.
Thanks so much, Dawn.
Well, just quickly to say that it
was a pleasure to work with you,
too, on on that piece, and
it's, it's really an honor
to, to have written it in
Larry's honor. So
the next speaker would have been
Barry Langford. But he is not
here. So I will just, as his
colleague and friend at Royal
Holloway I will just advertise his
article and which is
on film,
American Films and The
Americanization of
the Holocaust.
And it is a brilliant piece which
shows, as has already been said,
how, how Larry's
ideas, in this case about the
Americanization of the Holocaust,
were in many ways
way ahead of their time.
How in some ways they have been
criticized by more recent
scholarship.
But he returns the argument full
circle and goes back to
Larry's ideas and shows why
they're still important for
continuing to understand American
films about the Holocaust.
So it's really a wonderful piece.
So our final contributor is
Gabi Finder, who's also,
as you know, one of the co editors
and Gabi in the Department of
Germanic Languages and Literature
at the University of Virginia.
So, Gabi.
Thank you very much Dan.
I, too, have many thanks.
I don't know, I didn't know the poem
by Merwin, but Dawn, please
send it to me after the webinar.
I loved what you said.
First off, I want to thank the
Journal of Holocaust Research,
formerly Dapim. I
want to thank
Michal Aharony, who was our editor,
who helped shepherd this vine to
fruition.
I also want to thank the
administrative director of the
journal, Anat Weiner, who is
extremely patient with us.
It was a long process, but the
product is very good, I
think. I want to thank my
guest coeditors, for inviting
me to join them.
They were the ones who conceived
the idea.
I'm not sure why they asked me, but
when they did, I was thrilled to
join them. And it was really
a joint effort and
a labor of love.
And so I want to thank Dan
and Dawn so much for inviting
me to be part of
this.
I want to thank the contributors to
the special issue.
Every contribution is special
in its own way, and
the issue covers such a wide range
from literature, thanks
to Sara, and philosophy,
thanks to Jenny,
and testimonies,
thanks to Noah, and
Dawn and Dan's analysis
of Karski's various testimonies.
Larry's analysis of the
Americanization of the Holocaust
through film, especially through the
film, which I love, Inglorious
Basterds, but I now understand
why I like it better, thanks to
Larry's article. And for me also, I
will speak about my own contribution
in a few minutes. And I'm so glad
that this was the opportunity I've
been looking for to write about this
particular piece.
Thank you, Stephen who
I think is...not I think, I know is
a new friend of mine.
Thank you, Stephen, for hosting
this and being a friend.
I want to thank the Fortunoff
Archives.
Thank you, Joanne, for your
wonderful tribute to Larry in your
introductory essay.
It really brings Larry's life
to life.
You know, instead of...we write
a bit in the abstract, and Joanne
brought Larry to life.
Finally, I must thank Professor
Lawrence Langer.
He's meant a lot to me in my career.
He doesn't know that, but he has
meant a lot to me in my career.
But I also want to talk about...I
want to mention a personal story
that is very important to me, just
briefly in my career.
Those of you who know me and know my
work, know that I've written a lot
about Jewish honor courts,
courts that Jewish communities
established after the Holocaust
to investigate fellow Jews accused
of having dirty hands.
And Larry's
notion or concept of choiceless
choices meant a lot to me
as I have worked on this topic for
years now and continue to
work on it.
In general, Larry's
empathic and forthright
approach to the Holocaust, to
Holocaust testimony has
been an inspiration to me and I've
tried to emulate him.
But I have a special personal story
that I have to share with all of
you, because it's been important to
me and to my family and to my
life, really.
And Larry knows what I'm talking
about and Dan knows what I'm talking
about. Joanne knows what I'm talking
about.
So my father is with us today.
My father and Larry are two months
apart. I believe that my father is
exactly two months older
than Larry, both for 91.
My father, Herbert Finder, is
with us today. My dad is a Holocaust
survivor. My mother also and her
family left Germany after
the night of Broken Glass.
But my dad with, with my
grandfather, went through several
camps as a
youn, as a boy, really.
And for years, I tried
to persuade my dad
to give testimony,
audio testimony.
He'd once gave in the 1980s, he
gave testimony
on a cassette tape
to Nora Levin.
And that actually... one can find
that on the website of the United
States Holocaust Memorial Museum.
But, you know, I wanted my dad to do
what other survivors
have done. So, you know, so
important to give out your
testimony. I couldn't persuade him,
even though he had such an
interesting story,
because he always felt that
younger people who would interview
him, wouldn't really understand
him, couldn't understand what he
went through. So he once said, if he
could find...if I could persuade
him, find someone who would
understand his story,
he would do it.
Well, I thought of Lawrence Langer,
but I didn't really know
Larry.
And then I was at an, maybe the same
AJS conference in Baltimore, to
which Noah referred earlier, and
after...no one was even on that
panel, I believe, if I'm not
mistaken. Joanne was on the panel.
My good friend Avinoam Patt was on
the panel.
And afterwards, I was scared to
death, intimidated because
who am I? I'm just a minor scholar
and Larry is such a major scholar.
He was on the panel.
But anyway, I went afterwards and
I said...we had met once
before, years ago, he didn't
remember...I said, Professor Langer,
you know, I admire your work so much
and my dad is a Holocaust survivor
and he's probably more or less your
age, and he always said that he
wouldn't give testimony, he has such
an important story to tell, but
he won't do it because he feels that
younger people wouldn't understand
him, and he said that you would
understand him, would you mind doing
this? And this was about five or six
years ago. Larry was retired and
lives in Boston.
The Fortunoff Archive, of course, is
in New Haven.
I said, would you do it? And he said,
without blinking, and I said yes.
And it was about five years
ago in the summer, I drove my dad
from New Jersey to New
Haven.
And Joanne was very gracious to be
there, too.
And Joanne
and Larry interviewed my dad.
And I just want to say...it
was a couple of hours. Stephen was
there in the control room.
That's where I first met Stephen.
And I just want to say that, that
testimony, I think it's...you know,
it's important.
But to my family and to me, it's
a gift.
You know, because it's something
that I will always
have. And my children,
that's what really important to me,
it's my children have it.
And I will never forget....how
my children, how they...when
they saw that testimony for the
first time, what an effect
it had on them. And they saw it
together with my dad and
I...I just, it
is etched in my mind
forever. My daughter, or my
child, even wants to write a
music to it.
So it's just, it's a gift to me
and my family.
And I just...Larry, you've given me
and my family a great gift,
and I can never thank you
enough for it.
So I write about...my article
is called...I'll speak about a very
briefly, and my article is called
"A Horrific Impression of Jewish
Martyrdom: Regarding Extermination
of Polish Jews: Album of Pictures."
And I write about an album
of photographs
called...it was a multilingual
folder, a volume of photographs
from the Holocaust...in Polish it's
Zaglada Zydostwa Polskiego: Album
Zdjec. It's translated
as Extermination of Polish Jews
Album of Pictures.
It was published in 1946
by the Jewish, Central Jewish
Historical Commission in Poland.
To the best of my knowledge, this
is the first album of its
kind published by a Jewish
institution after the Holocaust,
that is Holocaust of photographs.
I'm not...everybody who knows me
knows that I'm a dinosaur when it
comes to these things.
But I'm going to try to share my
screen.
Can you...whoops, wrong thing.
Let's see, my son is here.
Maybe he can help me.
Hello, can you...this? Yes.
Oh, there it is. Can you see that?
Does everybody see that?
So that's the album
that I used
and it's gone, as you see.
And now...can you bring me back
to Stop Share?
OK. So there I am.
Thank you.
It's good to have a young person
with me to help me with me these
things.
My son is here helping me.
So this was...this album
is, to the best of my knowledge, the
first album of its kind.
And it shows Holocaust...photographs
from the Holocaust in the, within
a one year after the end of World
War Two and the Holocaust, the
Central Jewish Historical Commission
in Poland had collected some
3000 photographs
from the Holocaust.
And the interesting thing
or the catch is that
most of the photos were taken
by Germans.
How they came into
the possession of Jews after the war
is an interesting story in itself.
Many Germans took...they
took their lightweight cameras.
They took photographs of
every aspect of the Holocaust,
you know, to mock the Jews, to
torment them.
They showed themselves having a
great grand old time
tormenting and killing Jews.
They had those art photographs
developed by Polish developers,
even some Jewish developers in
ghettos. They replicated them.
They gave them to friends.
And they were circulating throughout
Nazi occupied Poland and other
places.
And both Poles and Jews
came into possession of many of
those photographs, both during and
after World War
Two and the Holocaust.
The album,
when a majority of the photographs
in the archives, photo archives
of the Central Jewish Historical
Commission were German produced
photographs.
There were also some that were taken
by Jews and even by Poles.
But the majority of the photographs
had been taken by Germans.
And the album, which
contains some 250 photographs,
the majority of the photos
in that album are German
produced photographs.
And I...in my
article, I discussed the dilemma
that the Jewish
Historical Commission and the editor
of this album
faced, and that was they
had...they wanted to
produce an album of photographs from
the Holocaust. They wanted to
evoke moral outrage
among an international community.
But they were stuck with a
majority of photographs
from the German perspective of
what
scholars called the German gaze.
And I make the
argument in my
article that the editor...could
you help me again for a second again?
So I want to just show you the...this
one. Which
one is it? This one.
Oh, hold on.
Oh, there it is. Can you all see
that?
It's good to have a 20 year old son
in college who can help with these
things.
And this is the editor
of the album
Gershon Taffet, who himself was a
Holocaust survivor, who survived
the liquidation of his ghetto
Zólkiew, who also survived the
Janowska, the infamous, notorious
Janowska labor camp outside
Lvov/L'viv, who lost his wife and
daughter. And then after
the Holocaust, joined the Central
Jewish Historical Commission and
became the director of its photo
archive or one of the directors and
the editor of this
volume.
So I'm back. So I argued
that even with
the inherent limitations of these
photos. Taffet and his colleagues
on the Jewish Historical Commission
decided to produce this
volume because they wanted...their
aim was to bring an international
mass audience closer
to the horrors of the Nazi
persecution and
murder of Jews.
And I also a show a few
of these photographs in my
album...in my article.
I don't want to, I decided
not to show the most horrific and
the worst of the photographs.
But I do want to show...I did show
one so-called buddy picture.
And I'm going to ask my son...hello,
this
one...can you show that one please?
That one? Yes. No, no, no, this one.
There it is.
Can you see that?
Yeah, so that is a photograph
of a reserve police battalion 101.
And all of you know, all of you in
the field, know it from Christopher
Browning's book Ordinary Men.
This was the reserve police
battalion that was at the center of
Christopher Browning's
investigation.
And it's a classic book, Ordinary
Men. And this is a photo I have...I
published this photo in my article.
It's a police reserve police
battalion 101, after a
ghetto roundup and deportation of
some 1000 Jews
in the ghetto Miedzyrzec Podlaski
in Poland.
They were deported to
Majdanek on May 26th, 1943.
And it's a gleeful...in
it you see the gleeful members
of Reserve Police Battalion 101
pointing to the spoils
that they took from the Jewish
victims that they had just deported
to
Majdanek. And, you know,
it's so hard to
divine what the
motivation of
these men were.
And Christopher Browning,
in his most recent volume of...the
Third Edition, revised edition, of
his book Ordinary Men,
points to the
fusion.
When we tried to understand
motivation, we should think
about the synergy
between situation
and ideology.
And I agree with that, for
the most part. But I think what this
does also show...this picture
shows that, and
the other pictures that appear in
the album, show what
I just said, calling
my article the creation
of a permissive
environment, a
de facto open season
on Poles, Poland's Jews
in which men in this
battalion could torment,
deport and kill Jews
with impunity.
And I borrow a phrase from
my colleague and good friend, Alon
Confino,
whose book is called A World Without
Jews. It seems to me that the
photographs that
appear in this album from 1946
display an attitude
among the Germans who took them
that they could imagine a world
without Jews.
That's the argument that I make.
But there's more to the album than
just that.
At the end of the
album, the editor, Gershon
Taffet, inserted a few photos
taken by Jews that extoll
Jewish resistance.
And I argue that it's an attempt
to subvert the so-called German
gaze in the album
with the Jewish gaze.
And I just want to show you one
more...could you show?
Thank you.
Is it this one? Yes, thank you.
Okay, one sec. Hold for tech.
Hey, Gabi?
Yes, I have...30
seconds.
Okay, great.
Thank you.
This one. Yes.
OK. Does anyone see that?
And that's a photo collage
that was made in the Lodz ghetto in
1941 by a survivor who
took the name in Israel, Arie
Ben-Menachem.
It's called "Przwtrawamy." It means
"we shall survive." So this
is how the album ends.
It ends on a hopeful note.
But I just want to say that...I
also am
a great fan of Larry's work, and
I am, of course, familiar with
his concept of unheroic
memory.
And I just want to say that even
though it ends on a hopeful
note, one,
the whole album, though,
is permeated by
this idea of
unheroic memories.
So there's this tension
in the album between
ending on a high note and
attestation of the horror
that befell Polish Jews during the
Holocaust.
Thank you very much.
And I want to thank everyone for
their contribution to
the special issue.
Thank you so much, Gabi.
Good.
Well, that's all the contributors.
I just wanted to add
a little personal note, which
is that like many others,
I met Larry
first, for the first time when I was
a postdoc in the mid 90s,
was also rather intimidated
because, of course, you know, he was
Lawrence Langer.
And it wasn't so many years since
I read
the Holocaust testimonies book and
was kind of overwhelmed.
And Larry paid
me the great honor of taking me
seriously and treating me
like, like a peer.
And he read parts of my doctorate.
And we talked about it
and made me feel as though
I was
an equal and had a contribution to
make. And it was really wonderful,
was extremely important for me
at that point in my career to
be treated like that by
somebody like Lawrence Langer.
So my own personal thanks
as well to add to, to those
of everybody else's.
And on that, I
would like now to invite
Larry to respond, to
say a few words. Whatever, whatever
you like. Over to you.
Well, can you hear me?
We can hear you.
You can hear me, all right.
Well have about 100 things to say
and only time to say about five of
them. Before I forget, Gabi,
it's very nice to have a 20 year
old son to help you with things.
My friend, it's even nicer to have
his 63 year old son, who is
a grandfather, to help
you with things.
So be prepared.
You have a great future ahead of
you. My son is my right arm
and my left arm.
Unfortunately, I wish you hadn't
said one thing
and it had to be echoed by
Dan. My entire
adult life, my wife has been
asking me, why do you intimidate
people so much?
And I tell her, me, you know,
the nicest guy in the world, I never
intimidate anyone.
The minute this webinar is over,
my wife is going to charge into my
arms. There, you see, you see, not
only did you intimidate Gabi, you
intimidated Dan,
you know, own up to it.
Well, it's still not true.
Now,
my young friends, let me tell
you something.
I think you
made the mistake of saying,
well, the festschrift is
a little late.
Does a year...what's in a year?
Be prepared.
Be prepared when you reach my age
there's a lot in a year.
Now in writing my essay, which I'm
not going to talk about...my life.
I was reminded of something that I
hadn't thought about before.
When I visited Dachau in 1955,
Raul Hilberg was a graduate student.
Christopher Browning was in
junior high school.
And this blows my mind
more than anything, my...late
in life dear friend
Wendy Lower was not even born.
And so I've had to deal with
this issue with the passage of time.
Now, there
is no point in my repeating
the thanks to everyone, you again
and again. Thank you, everyone.
I just want to mention, I'm sure I
have no idea how much
time and energy Dan
and Dawn and Gabi must've
put into preparing
this volume.
I would like to add one thanks which
no one would mention because they
didn't know what to mention.
The cover of this
print, the in print
festschrift is a painting by the
child survivor of the Vilna ghetto,
Samuel Bak, called the Creation
of Adam.
And I would like to thank Bernie
Pucker of the Pucker gallery in
Boston for given permission
to use that painting.
And I hope those of you who will
be...who
will be getting a copy
of the print version will look at
that painting because
it's Sam Bak's post Holocaust
version of Michaelangelo's
famous
version of the creation of Adam on
the ceiling of Sistine Chapel.
And when you look at the Adam,
you have to ask the question
that Primo Levi
asked, is this a man?
And not only that, when you look at
the image of God
in that painting, you have to ask
the question...to ask less often,
is this a God?
So that painting really
creates a kind of introduction
to that volume.
Now, I read each of these essays
twice and
was extraordinary. The second time
through,
I realized
things I didn't read the first time
through...that these are
such serious
investigations of such a variety
of issues.
And I just offer my heartfelt thanks
to all of you for contributing
to this volume.
One of the things I noticed, and I
don't have time to talk about it,
is that there is a kind of
interaction, unintended, of course,
because you haven't read each
other's contributions,
the relationship
between some of these essays.
Just imagine, Dawn
and Gabi, if
Jan Karski had been
able to walk into the office
of President Roosevelt's
carrying Gabi's volume
under his arm and trying to get
President Roosevelt to understand
what he's trying to tell him when
he went in and looked at
the condition of the Jews in
the Warsaw ghetto.
I want you to think about one thing,
neither in your essay or in your
presentation now have you shown us
a picture of one of these atrocity
photographs.
And I'd like you to think about why.
Because we need to see them.
And I hope you will in an e-mail
tell me, how can I get a copy of
this? None of the libraries that I
checked, they have a copy.
I'm the reason we have them here.
Now,
what I appreciate most about
these essays is that instead
of answering questions, they
raised questions, all kinds
of questions that have no answers
and even
may be unanswerable.
And I want to show
two examples at the essays...Jennifer
and her wonderful essay on
Primo Levi writes
the following, just
one sentence, "considering
if something is so,
is not a questioning that
produces an answer.
Rather, it is a dwelling with a
painful reality that cannot
be resolved.
And brackets judgment, requiring
our continued attention, time
and ongoing reflection,
even though we can't go, can't be
resolved." I think it's, it's a gem
of a sentence, Jennifer.
And thank you
for it.
The other really
moment that concentrates
in a sentence, is in
Sara's essay...and
Sara, thank you so much.
I never heard of Sarah Kofman in my
life before where you
mentioned her.
And for some reason, my local
library had a copy of her book,
which I took out and thank God it
was only 80 pages, so I read it.
I'm currently reading the new
biography
by Volker Ullrich of Adolf
Hitler. Each one weighs about 10
pounds.
Each one is about 800 pages
long. And just imagine, I mean,
Hitler came to power once, it's
eighty three years ago.
And in 2020, this year volume
two came out full of
information that
hadn't been used before.
So this subject is not
dead and will never die.
Let me read you just that
other sentence from Sarah Kofman's
book: "Because he was a Jew, my
father died in Auschwitz.
How can it not be said
and how can it be said?
How can one speak of that before
which all possibility of speech
ceases?" Now,
behind that line,
there exist questions
which will never have an answer,
because she found out later what
happened to her father, her father,
a rabbi, an Orthodox Jew
who refused to work
on the Sabbath.
So as a punishment, the
Germans buried him
alive.
And I asked myself, these are the
questions that rise. Who
gave that order? Who
dug that hole?
What were the onlookers thinking
while it was happening?
And what was her
rabbi father thinking
as the dirt piled up around
him? These are questions raised by
the Holocaust for which we don't
have the answers, but for
which we are obliged, about
which we're about,
we are obliged to think.
I have a lot of reflections on that.
But, you know, we've gone more than
an hour. I just want to say one more
thing and then I'm going to stop
because there may be questions and
we need to allow time for
that.
I watched a interview many
years ago, an interview
at the Fortunoff Archives
from a man who told his story.
At the very end, the interviewer
made what I consider to be a mistake
of asking him, do you have any final
comments that you like to
offer us?
That is usually an invitation for a
little moral homily about the
need to, the
need to be good to people
and be kind and not to bully and so
forth.
That's not what he did.
He said...all my life, he says,
I've been haunted by
a question
and this is the mode in which I like
to end.
What's the question?
He said, what
happened to my mother?
When they killed her.
Was she alone? Was she with other
people? Was
she afraid?
What was she thinking?
I'll let you know, and he said, I'll
never know.
So an important dimension
of Holocaust studies, and
it happened in so many of these
essays is
exposing questions
for which there is no answer and
for which we are nonetheless obliged
to continue, continue
searching for one.
So I hope you young
people, and I say that
from my position as someone who
is now going on 92, to carry on with
this kind of work.
It's almost inconceivable
that we're approaching a century
from the time when Hitler came to
power.
And essays like these are still
being written.
And I hope they will continue
to be for
a long, long time.
I mean, I bless you all, paying
such attention to what I have done.
You can't imagine how good
this all makes me feel.
And being friends
and not people
I'm intimidated, but being friends
have meant so much to me.
And just looking at you
fills my heart with warmth. So thank
you, thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you, Larry.
It's an enormous honor and a
pleasure for all of us, I think, to,
to hear your words and
we're not intimidated anymore.
We were just, just reflecting
on on the early days.
It's really wonderful to hear what
you say.
I think I'm speaking for myself,
what...what you say
about asking questions
that cannot be answered is really
goes to the heart of things, I
think, and particularly
for historians who like
to answer questions.
In this
subject, extremely
important to remember,
I think what you've taught us, which
is that there is no redemptive
message to be gained
from studying the Holocaust.
And there are no final answers
in history or in
any other respect.
And I think that's an enormous
contribution and continues to be
something that has to be repeated
over and over again, particularly
given the state of
public engagement with the Holocaust
and some of the immense
analyzation that take place
on a daily basis.
So we're all immensely
grateful to you for your work.
And I will also
finally add here a little
advertisement, which is that Larry
was too modest to mention that
another collection of his own essays
will be published in
the New Year with Palgrave.
So we have more of Larry's work
still to look forward to.
It's called the...it's the "After
Death of the Holocaust" is the
title.
After Death of the
Holocaust...coming, coming
to a book...
February.
Thank you, Larry. Stephen, do we
have time to take a question?
Of course.
There's actually one here, Larry,
that you might like to respond
to, which I don't
know, we don't have a name.
An anonymous attendee says
the great presence of some art,
for example, the art of
Samuel Bak in your writing since
1995, please comment.
And you already have, obviously, on
the painting, which adorns
the cover of the journal.
But I wonder if you'd like to say
anymore about, about Samuel Bak's
work.
Yes,
I came late in life to the work
of Sam Bak. We have now done eleven
volumes together.
He does a series of paintings
and I write a long essay.
And Bernie Pucker, through his
wizardry, managed to get
the volumes published
right now.
And I'll just say two or three
sentences about Sam, because this is
not really about Sam.
But along with
Felix Nussbaum, they for me
are the two great artists of the
Holocaust.
But Sam tries
to present visually
the way the Holocaust has fractured
our world in the years
after the war.
It's a unique contribution
to the world of art.
He should be better known.
But I mean, people tell me
again and again, I
can't hang a painting like that in
my living room because I have to
look at it.
Well, it's like looking at the
photographs in
these volume.
We can't look at it but we have to
look at it.
But if you're interested in pursuing
the work of Sam Bak and it's
certainly worth pursuing, just
go onto
Puckergallery.com, go into artists,
go
into Samuel Bak.
You'll be able to see a lot of his
paintings, they're really worth
investigating.
Thank you, Larry.
There's a comment here from
Wendy Lauer, it's nice
that Wendy's here.
And Wendy
says
she wants to pay tribute to, to your
work and cites
one of the, one particular
sentence that you've, that you've
written.
"When human beings cease
to be emissaries or legatees
of love and become instead agents
or victims of power on such
a massive scale, we may have
witnessed a shift in civilization's
priorities with whose
psychological bequest we continue
to struggle."Would
you like to comment or
leave it as it stands?
Ask me November 4th. Alright, and
I'll comment then.
Alright, I understand. I understand.
In that case, Stephen, do we want to
trickle things to a close?
I think so. There was one question,
one other question about how to
obtain a copy of the journal.
I don't know if you want to just say
a few words about
how to get a copy of the journal.
Well, for...of course, for those
with institutional subscriptions
to Taylor and Francis
journals, it can be obtained
through your institutional library.
I think for those who, who don't
have access to a university
library, perhaps
if you go to the...maybe Michal can
comment. But perhaps if you go to
the website of the Journal of
Holocaust Research, you'll be able
to see what access options
there are there.
But perhaps you could also email
Michal Aharony and
ask her about that as well.
Otherwise, I think that's, that's
all the questions.
So it just falls
to me to, to say thank
you to the contributors.
Again, thank you to Stephen and to
Fortunoff Archive.
Thank you to Michal and the
Journal of Holocaust Research.
And most of all, thank you to Larry.
We're deeply
honored to be able to celebrate
your work in this way.
Wish you a happy birthday
and many more to come.
Thank you.